Yuria.
Defiled, and dressed in rags..you might not
mark her as a witch if not for that iconic,
pointed hat.
Legends attest that witches have been wearing
this peculiar style of headwear since long
ago..which implies that "magic women".. were
common back then.
Tour the nexus, and you will find a plethora
of statues depicting women; wrapped in robes,
masked by hoods.
Befriend the monumental, and she reveals that
she too is female.
For in Demon's Souls, women have a unique
capacity for the Soul Arts.
For them, sorcery is commonly an art of emotion..intuited
from feeling, rather than developed through
contemplation.
For witches, sorcery is an art of emotion..intuited
from feeling,
Freke wields a different kind of magic from
my witchcraft.
Freke's magic stems from an understanding
of the essence of the Demon soul,
while my witchcraft merely channels its energy.
If the Demon is cursed, so shall be the witchcraft.
Freke's power comes from human potential,
while mine is a dark, dependent art.
So when you find a Demon Soul, you take it
to Yuria to manifest its power..not Freke.
I feel great misgivings about Freke.
I was branded a witch at a very young age,
and since then, I have been persecuted as
a threat to human society.
Although I never had ill-intentions, this
black craft of mine is intrinsically evil.
If there is a God, he gave us souls to do
good, not to practice witchcraft.
My accusers detested my dark arts for good
reason, for the path I have taken is tainted.
This has been one of my realizations since
coming to Boletaria.
But I am afraid that Freke, too, has ventured
down the wrong path.
He has become obsessed with the dark arts.
Her sorcery differs from mine, rather they
are arts of emotion and feel closer to miracles.
Perhaps it’s because she’s a woman…?
Is having it all beyond my grasp…?
- Japanese Dialogue w/ english subtitles
The Dark Arts, and Witches, have such an evil
reputation..because here in this nexus, years
ago..women did what men could not.
Here, their unique proficiency for Soul Magic
was used to its fullest potential..to worship,
study..and eventually awaken the Old One.
This led to the first scourge.
To demons, and to the defilement of half the
world.
If there was any one member responsible for
awakening The Old One, then it was the Maiden
in Black.
This witch demonstrates a motherly tenderness
with the demon, and was one of its most powerful
servants during this time.
Like other witches, she would have channeled
its power..and the power of the Old One was
dark indeed.
It absorbs souls - claiming them through a
network of demons in the fog.
Countless would end up displaced fleeing the
ever-creeping and all-consuming fog, exacerbating
the number of impoverished refugees.
Busy with the war, no nation accepted these
poor men and women, forcing them all to wander
the earth, with only the sympathetic clergy,
spiritual healers, and witch doctors to guide
them onward.
Skewered with spears likely dropped from the
nexus, the Old One appeared unkillable.
So with countless souls lost, the fabric of
reality broken, and kingdoms reduced to ruin..the
Monumentals settled for a half measure.
They forced the Old One into slumber, imprisoned
it in their temple, and took it to the far
reaches of human habitation, where they hoped
the beast might never be disturbed again.
The Maiden, defiled, and dressed in black..was
blinded with wax, and forced to tend to the
candles within the shrine.
She is the shame of the monumentals, a disastrous
product of their culture's obsession with
magic.
dressed in black..was defiled.
The monumentals punished her, blinding the
immortal with wax, and forcing her to tend
to the candles within the shrine.
She is their shame, a product of their culture’s
obsession with magic
The monumentals have punished the Maiden in
Black severely, blinding the shacked immortal
with wax, and . And because of this arrogance,
their entire civilization was destroyed along
with much of the world.
To repair the fabric of reality, six archstones
were constructed and given to the remaining
leaders of men.
The ambitious king saddled atop a tiny nation..
The digger king whose people mined the underground..
The intelligent queen holding the keys to
the ivory tower..The priest to shadowmen glorifying
death and storms..
The giants that lay claim to the north.
And, yes, even the chief of those wandering
poor.
The ambitious king..the digger king..the intelligent
queen..the priest to the shadowmen, the giants..and
yes, even to the chief of those wandering
poor.
Starved of magic during this period, many
of these cultures collapsed.
With no magic arts to heal them, and no nation
welcoming the poor, the chief of the wandering
poor led his vagrants deep into the western
valley, where no one would mind their poverty.
This place?
It's a proper mound of rubbish.
All the rot of the world, living or not, ends
up here.
Here, anarchy reigns.
The poor scavenge for food, shelter, and wares..diseased
vermin bite and suck their soiled skin..merchants
lie and cheat, and a cannibal roams the swamp.
It should come as no surprise then, that the
Chief's duty to their archstone was quickly
forgotten.
Why should they care about the outside world,
when it had all but abandoned them?
To make matters worse.. above, a new religion
was gaining power..
A priesthood from the land of Mird, whose
temples quickly came to span the continent,
especially in the Western Highlands.
They had a belief in a singular deity - a
God who seeks all that is pure and good, and
rejects all that is impure and evil.
As a result, we see higher-ranking priests
achieve saintly status by remaining pure in
every sense - sequestering themselves in their
temples, devoted to prayer, reciting miracles
that reject death, selfishness, disease, poison..but
most reviled of all: was magic.
But most of all..the priesthood reviled magic.
It was those evil sorcerers and magicians
that caused a near-apocalypse, so the priests’
anti-magic stance made it ripe for popularity.
They built upon the Monumentals' ban on such
power, taking steps to oppress any who practice
the craft..regardless of intention or circumstance.
Yuria serves as our foremost example.
Yet..witches like Yuria still cling to their
black arts, finding their talents to be their
one solace against their persecutors.
Now..while the Soul Arts are a distant memory
at this point in history..artifacts from this
bygone age still exist.
Take the Ring of Magical Nature, for example
- cursed witches were believed to be born
holding this ring..making artifacts like these
objects of extreme fear..and superstition.
Unless the church found them, of course.
Then, they were considered divine revelations
instead.
How convenient.
There was the Moonlight Sword, granted to
Temple Knight Vizo.
The Istarelle, given to temple knight Rizaia.
Blind, given to Selen Vinland..and Bramd,
taken up by her brother Garl.
But perhaps most special of all..was the Ring
of Sincere Prayer.
An artifact found by a truly lucky (Source:
Blueblood Sword) young girl..leading to her
instant rise as the Sixth Saint.
Astraea.
(note: The Japanese specifically elevates
holy women, as opposed to the more common
"saint" urbain)
So is she a saint..or a witch?
Well..she's both, in a way.
For they are one and the same.
It's here, that we arrive at the biggest twist
Demon's Souls has to offer.
That magic and miracles are two sides of the
same coin..and that the Old One is at the
heart of it all.
Prayer is for the foolish, quaint, and soon-to-be
dead.
And heaven forbid the day you find out what
their so-called God really is…
Why else would all their most powerful saints
be women?
Why else were miracles energized alongside
magic when the Old One was awakened?
Why do the priests talismans of god..resemble
the Old One?
It's simple.
Because their so-called God..is the old one.
His miracles..are the Soul Arts..and women
can more easily channel this magic..whether
they be witches..or saints.
With the loss of history, later generations
found certain magic indistinguishable from
their conception of divine power, associating
anything somehow unclean with malice.
The temple believes whatever best suits their
politics..so when they cast their arrogant
gaze towards the denizens of the valley, they
didn't see the needy..they saw sinners being
punished by god.
However, this couldn't be farther from the
truth.
I find something odd about this place.
It brims with grime, but at once feels strangely
pure.
The lost and unclean are simply victims of
circumstance.
Circumstances that the temple created, when
they abandoned them.
Circumstances that Astraea, the Sixth Saint..set
out to resolve.
During the early years of the Second Scourge,
the Sixth Saintess was quick to embark on
a relief mission to Boletaria.. and in the
years after entering the tear, she discovered
the existence of the valley.
That witch Astraea came to this valley with
that squid-headed knight.
Those ridiculous white robes of hers…
I swear I caught her glaring at my son in
disgust!
Yes, yes it's true!
For a woman whose luck saved her from both
poverty and plague, seeing the poor and afflicted
came as a shock, which the filthy woman misinterpreted
as contempt.
In truth, the clergywoman’s heart ached
for their suffering.
And she began to question for the first time:
Why had God permitted their pain?
If there is natural evil, it is not those
forced to live in the valley.
It is God, so cruel and unjust to allow suffering
in His Creation.
And so, Astraea chose to bring salvation to
these people abandoned like the trash of the
valley.
But healing magic can only go so far.
In order to reach the root of the problem,
the former Sixth Saintess needed to take away
the source of thoughts which bring pain: the
soul.
And so, she became an Archdemon for the Old
One, gaining the power to rob the living of
their souls.
She embraced the filthy, ridding them of their
suffering..and for that, they revere her.
All the men worship her like she's the Virgin
Mary.
The same men who would snatch my child away
from me!
This was a much better place before she came.
I was the apple of every mans eye.
You’re here to rid us of her, aren't you?
Well, don't show her any mercy!
Astraea sits on a mountain of gold and corpses:
offerings from the men of the Valley, desperate
to repay their debt to the woman who loved
them.
Any soul will do - making it a terrifying
place for people like the Filthy Woman..and
the temple knights who embarked in pilgrimage
here.
Have you heard the rumours about Astraea of
the Valley of Defilement?
They claim that she and her loyal knight have
become Demons, and lead a clan of degenerate
miscreants.
In truth, the rumours are surely unfounded.
There are all sorts of wrongdoers down there
who would think up such nonsense.
…Yet if the rumours are true…
Then may she be eternally *****ed for her
debasement of the Lord's name!
By this point, her bodyguard Garl Vinland
should have stepped in and purified her for
her sacrilege, but it was no use.
He had seen the same things as she, and the
young noble knight bravely stood in solidarity
with her decision.
How dare you persist in intruding upon our
haven.
You abandoned us long ago; what right do you
have?
CHARACTER STARTS FIGHT WITH GARL
But good intentions do not make one immune
from spreading evil.
Instead, they simply heighten the tragedy.
KILL GARL
Dearest Astraea…
I have failed you.
(music swells)
WALK UP TO ASTRAEA, INITIATE DIALOGUE
You…
You killed him, didn't you?
Very Well, I can no longer resist you.
Do as you like.
Take your precious Demon soul.
Astraea..defiled, and dressed in white - has
a soul that grants spells of death, relief,
and resurrection.
She is, at once, the most impure demon of
all..but also closer to god than any saint
before her.
So ask yourself, Slayer of Demons.
Do
the ends, justify the means?